I'll go with you because here loves to
go Theo loves I love it too yeah I would
love to come I know I don't like to go I
gotta fix my knee I gotta fix it dude
I'm [ __ ] up does it requires surgery
that [ __ ] up we we don't know yet was
it from this I mean this is no no it
happened halfway through them check out
this though yeah this is nuts
oh oh my God
how crazy is that
but that was you did
you get to Micah George that's George
kicked his ass dude
that's yours they whooped him whoa and
then Jake came out oh Jake came out and
then beat him up oh my God look at this
Bobby you gotta do that you have to be
involved yeah I'll I'll die okay it's
unnecessary
Logan look at Logan yeah
whoa dude
oh wow the whole thing you're really
doing it dude I like it that's amazing
dude there's a whole thing there you are
kalila coming down
that's amazing baby yeah what what whoa
dude so wait you had a heart need this
whole fight bro halfway through the
match oh my God but the adrenaline's
going that that jump over the ropes onto
the twins that you saw yeah I wasn't
positive I could do it I I thought it
was gonna fully tear fall into the ropes
very big embarrassing moment for me I
didn't know how I was gonna finish the
match that's [ __ ] amazing dude it's
really hard man it's hard wow that's
like that's like a real skill set so so
so you'd be surprised how many people
[ __ ] love the WWE they love it like
there's a lot of there's a lot of
misconceptions about it and uh I think
it's perceived
the wrong way sometimes and also it's
super Niche too like if you're not
arrested it's so fun it's so it's fun so
if you grow up with it you understand
the mindset of how to properly enjoy the
WWE and it's endlessly entertaining
endlessly entertaining I used to watch
the tongue of the kid and Jimmy
supervise the snooka back I used to go
to the sports arena in San Diego to go
watch me and Will Sasso went to one I
mean I love it right will yeah yeah
Will's into it too yeah we [ __ ] love
it yeah yeah yeah when you're there and
you have someone you like that's the
game changer if you're invested in a
character
that's when it gets really fun and
especially watching that [ __ ] live I
don't know I don't know how half this
stuff is legal I don't know how it's
legal yeah aren't you scared though to
jump over into the floor I'm not scared
of much who's your favorite wrestler of
all time
oh really in the um WWE WWE
um
probably Jimmy's the snooper fly snooker
mine is Mick Foley yeah he was good Mick
Foley because he used to do you think of
a [ __ ] he would hurt I mean he would do
it all yeah he was insane yeah he was
insane so his body through it's just fun
man but like it's interesting coming
from boxing proper boxing yeah to
wrestling and comparatively
gauging interest and
and Effectiveness in terms of what and
how I want to build my career yeah dude
like I don't know what it is about
wrestling people I've never gotten that
many texts about anything in my in my
life yeah yeah like way more than the
Floyd thing way more than anybody yeah I
did way more than the announcement Prime
but like
people love it it's insane and like dude
even the reception on my Instagram the
videos get 20 look look you might not
have seen this so that that jump off the
table yeah I filmed it I filmed it
myself on my phone look
oh [ __ ] wow
[Music]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] dude oh my God but I
filmed it the clip has they got it's a
WWE's most viral clip ever wow like 50
million views in like a two oh my God
that's [ __ ] insane insane bro so
there's so much room for me to be the
creative that I am at heart because at
the end of the day I'm just I'm just a
Creator who works hard but it's just
such a creatively open environment that
suits my physicality really well but you
would be terrifying in an octagon
because it's like a lot of these guys
who like cross over there is like oh
there they have a boxing background but
you're just [ __ ] agile all around
yeah I think I think that's why I wanted
I need to I need to do one MMA fight and
I want it to be against Andrew [ __ ]
date I mean that would for me that's
just an easy one why why because he's a
kickboxer